abl bollywood par la conquête de l'ouest
bollywood c'est la contraction à
d'hollywood et de bombay les deux
capitales mondiales du septième art le
cinéma indien très productif s'exporte
de plus en plus c'est arrive sur les
écrans français avec la sortie
aujourd'hui de coup de foudre à
bollywood
tous les ingrédients qui font le succès
de ce cinéma indien sont réunis de
l'amour de la musique de la danse et des
acteurs jeunes et beaux nathalie était
ramed rexel c'est un monde où il fait
bon vivre
les hommes sont amoureux et ils disent
les femmes sont magnifiques et le sable
jeux de séduction et regards qui en
disent long
coup de foudre à bollywood c'est du
cinéma indien pur jus mais à deux
exceptions près d'abord les dialogues
sont dans la langue de shakespeare
ensuite c'est d'un roman anglais dont il
s'inspire orgueil et préjugés de jane
austin où la rencontre de deux êtres que
tout sépare
m
cinq idées souk
bonnel quête d'aragorn
tu dors plus
j'avais envie de faire un film
typiquement bollywoodien mais pas
forcément typiquement indien
c'est pourquoi j'ai réalisé une version
anglo-saxonne
d'autre part j'ai pensé que ce film
permet d'attirer un nouveau public un
public de ne connaissant pas forcément
du goût de bollywood
entendez par là la contraction de bombay
la mecque du cinéma indien et de
hollywood
car ce sont plus de 1000 films qui sont
produits chaque année en 1 2 soit deux
fois plus qu'aux états unis volume ou de
ces plusieurs milliards de spectateurs à
travers le monde
une des mesures à l'image du cinéma
lui-même des sagas de trois ou quatre
heures des décors somptueux et d'
invraisemblable mais l'eau le tout
chanté dansé version 100% fitch mais
cela plaît et pas seulement en inde
ici à paris ce vidéo clubs spécialisés
ne désemplit pas on les loue par les hlm
avait vocaux veiller à vos comédiens
préférés
bah oui charles crâne je le rendrai à
chaleur en beaucoup d'autres à doullens
pâle et choix ria rice et l excuse monde
est aujourd'hui superstar de beaux du
monde en 2002 le film devdas dans lequel
elle tient le rôle titre et sélectionné
à cannes un an plus tard mademoiselle
rails et membre du prestigieux jury
aucun doute le cinéma indien s'ouvre à
l'occident mais toute une nouvelle
génération de réalisateurs indiens à
étudier dans des écoles de cinéma
occidental
nourri de vos filles et de nos
traditions ils seront très efficace je
crois en 2001 c'est un film indien le
mariage des moussons qui obtenait le
lion d'or à venise
aujourd'hui la belle h comme on
l'appelle pourrait se voir proposer le
rôle de la prochaine james bond girl
c'est peut-être le début d'une
ère nouvelle pour bollywood qui devra
cependant veiller à ne pas perdre son
âme